.
IA
Pock or not Pock ist die Frage jetzt, ich glaube ich muss mal wieder eine Runde, ich
muss erstmal was trinken und dann ein Bonbon lutschen, dass der Hals nicht so trocken wird
beim ganzen labern jetzt.
Ansonsten, ich hab's gestern wieder gemerkt, das hat, also ich hab ja gestern zwischendurch
immer mal wieder was getrunken und das bringt halt bei vier Stunden Stream was, ich weiß
eh nicht wie die Leute das teilweise machen, es gibt ja Leute die Streamen irgendwie, keine
Ahnung, acht Stunden plus oder so, keine Ahnung wie das funktionieren soll, ich bin
nach vier Stunden Stream schon genug, das reicht mir schon.
Stripes 007 31 Monate, ahja ja, Pock, der Eichler auch 30 Monate am Start, danke für
die Subs Leute, Massive Subscriptions hier.
Um nicht zu sagen, das ist sogar Hypersomes Climber, ahja, ist nicht bald wieder Zeitumstellung,
ist nicht bald so weit, nee, ich glaube das dauert noch einen Monat, oder?
Ich glaube im März ist das irgendwann, ich kann einfach mal kurz gucken, Zeitumstellung,
ahja, hier, da, guck mal, da ist es.
27.
März, sag mal, sollte das nicht abgeschafft werden?
Haben wir nicht vor vier Jahren oder so irgendeine Abstimmung zugemacht, ob das nicht abgeschafft
wird?
Ah gut, ich meine ich hätte nicht ernsthaft damit gerechnet, dass da was rauskommt.
Wer macht heute Nacht wegen Superbowl, mir könnte, also es gibt weniger, was mir noch
egaler ist als der Superbowl, aber ich weiß, dass es einige wirklich interessiert, ich
habe auf der Arbeit auch einen Kollege, der wohnt gar nicht so weit weg hier von mir,
der, zwei sogar, die gucken auch immer Superbowl nachts, ja, bei jedem was ihm da gefällt.
Kona, ja, sind nicht auch gerade Olympische Spiele
bei den China-Chinesen?
Klickt man kaum was von mit.
Guck mal, was ich für eine Grausamkeit gefunden habe in PHP, ja gut, das ist ja wahrscheinlich
auch nicht schwierig, dass da raus, da was zu finden, oder?
PHP, Dollar A gleich, hallo.
Ach, du meinst das, was ist denn das?
Hä, das verstehe ich nicht, was?
Ah, der setzt hier hallo ein und benutzt dann hallo als Variable, boah, das ist ja mal
next level dynamischer Shit, ja, warum nicht, das ist halt PHP, PHP, muss ich ja nicht mehr
schämen, PHP ist ja schon bekannt dafür, übelst eklig und hässlich zu sein, dann
darf PHP auch übelst hässlich und eklig sein und die Leute erwarten das ja schon.
Ich habe auch, also weißt du, was ich am besten an PHP finde?
Also ich meine mal, davon abgesehen, dass es mit Sachen wie Laravel oder so durchaus
erträglich ist, aber das beste an PHP ist, dass es auf jedem 08, was es bei jedem, jedem
billigst noch so kleinen Kack-Hoster dabei ist, umsonst.
Finde mal ordentliche Packages für.NET Ruby und sonst was, das kannst du eigentlich vergessen,
da musst du dir entweder komplette, komplette VM mieten und das selbst machen oder halt
irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten, um das zu hosten, aber so ein einfaches Web-Hosting-Paket
ist halt mit den meisten Sachen nicht, außer PHP, das ist, das ist finde ich das mit Abstand
beste an PHP, dass es überall läuft.
Hast du schon mal das Quiz, JS ist weird gemacht, weird champ, nee, schick mal Link,
aber wir wissen, wir wissen, dass Javascript Pains Champ ist, ich kenn bloß die Batman,
dieses Batman-Ding mit Javascript, das machen wir heute gar nicht, machen wir heute Abend
vielleicht, wenn was geht.
Okay, true plus, oh okay, das ist Javascript, Moment, das ist, das ist Javascript, okay,
wir machen jetzt da nur eine Frage, true plus false, also ich würde, ich würde ja normalerweise
erwarten, dass plus eventuell, nicht spoilern Leute, nicht spoilern, true lulw, warum heißt
ihr wo plus, weil ich den Account erstellt hab, bevor ich angefangen hab zu streamen
und das ist so eigentlich ganz gut finde, also, man könnte jetzt erwarten, dass der
irgendwie sowas wie ein end macht oder so, macht er nicht, also ich vermute ja da kommt
ein String raus, weil er sagt, okay, true und false kann man nicht, ist plus nicht definiert
und deswegen macht er, macht er String, ist es, ist es ein String?
Was, hä, ist das ein leeres Array, ist, ist, ist es 0, das ist, das ist 0, 0, 0 oder was,
ist das undefined undefined undefined und davon die Länge, ja 3 oder, 3, okay, okay,
oh, hängt der Array hintereinander, keine Ahnung, also ich mein, es ist Javascript
und das hier ist mit Abstand das bescheuertste in der Antwort, deswegen wird es das wahrscheinlich
sein, ich könnte mir durchaus auch das, aber warum, warum kommt da überhaupt ein String
raus, dann, also das logischste wäre not a number, was auch immer, man weiß ja nie,
not a number ist bei Javascript immer möglich, 0.2 plus 1 gleich 3, true, false, ich hab,
ich hab keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich false, wahrscheinlich false, 10.2, ach ne 10,2, ist
das überhaupt gültiger Syntax, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es gültiger Syntax ist überhaupt,
ich sag einfach mal 10, der vergisst das danach, ich, keine Ahnung, was soll, Ausrufezeichen,
ist das gültiger Syntax, Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen, Quote, okay, das ist ein String, das ist not,
not String, also not, not, okay, okay, okay, leerer String not is true, da kommt false
raus Leute, guck mal, not, not, leerer String is true und not is false, hab ich recht, ach
du scheiße, leeres Array ist wahrscheinlich false, true, false, aber was macht denn das,
okay, plus, es ist false und es ist 0, da macht false zu einer 0, wenn man, wenn man
ein plus davor macht wahrscheinlich, ich rate jetzt einfach mal, ach du große Scheiß hör
der gar nicht mal auf, true, false, true, false, keine Ahnung, ne, das ist, das ist, das ist
tatsächlich, ich glaube das ist tatsächlich true, ne, ich glaube das ist true, true, String
gleich, ich glaube das ist true 0w, ja, 010, minus 3 sollte 7 sein oder, ist das nicht
7, warum, warum ist das in Javascript nicht 7, das ist oktal, ach du scheiße, das kann
ich jetzt noch im Kopf nicht rechnen, was ist denn da, 5, ist es oktal 5, weil die 10
ist in oktal eine 8, oder, ey Quatsch, Quatsch, Quatsch, das ist in oktal, ach scheiße, einfach
9, was ist das wieder für, ok, Lehrer String, minus, minus Lehrer String, in der Java Logik
ist es wahrscheinlich das hier, keine Ahnung, 0 plus 0, 0, 0 durch 0, not a number, jetzt
ist ja mal langsam gut, jetzt ist, jetzt übertreibt es mal nicht hier, 1 durch, was, keine, ey
Leute jetzt mal, was, was weiß ich denn, keine Ahnung, 1 durch 0 hätten wir jetzt erwartet,
is not a number, not a number größer, der Zahl, also ich vermute mal, dass das hier
ein Exponent ist, und das ist größer, is not a number größer dem, false, true plus plus,
2, 2, ist true plus plus 2, ok Lehrer String, minus 1, Lehrer String ist wahrscheinlich,
da kommt wahrscheinlich minus 1 raus, ok, 0, minus 0, alter, ich krieg da jetzt irgendwas
an, ich hab keine, Leute ich hab keine Ahnung, so, was, wie, correct, falsch, correct, falsch,
guck mal, das haben wir richtig gehabt, nice, aber das ist falsch, aber das haben wir, ok,
das haben wir richtig, nice, falsch, ok, richtig, es ist 5, keine Ahnung, 0 plus 0 ist 0, not
a number, das wusste ich, das hatten wir nämlich schon mal, ah guck mal, das ist richtig, was
wir gesagt haben, aha, true plus plus, ok und ab hier hab ich jetzt einfach durchgeklickt,
naja, meine Güte, also sowas, also ganz ehrlich, Javascript Sachen sind wirklich schon äußerst
painstamping, aber zum Glück kann man das meist umgehen, man muss das ja nicht so schreiben,
wenn man sich überlegt, dass Javascript ja irgendwie so in so einer Nacht und Nebelaktion
mit irgendwie so einem Mannteam oder so gebaut wurde, ja so genau sowas sollte ja normalerweise
auch keiner schreiben, aber trotzdem, in ordentlichen Programmiersprachen sollte man normalerweise
in der Regel so rausfiguren können, was ein Ausdruck macht, auf der anderen Seite kann
man wahrscheinlich in fast jeder Programmiersprache was so wir schreiben, also du kannst in C sharp
auch Sachen unverständlich schreiben, es wird immer dann unverständlich, wenn du beispielsweise
ohne zu klammern ganz viele Operator nebeneinander machst, dann musst du nämlich wissen, welcher
Operator mehr bindet als der andere und dann hört es dann irgendwann auf, so, was machen
wir jetzt Leute, gucken wir jetzt schon Videos, ah ja, wann war nochmal Zeitumstellung, 27
März, wann wird die Zeitumstellung 2022 abgeschafft, ja wahrscheinlich nicht 2022, ja wenn man
natürlich für die Zeitabschaffung ab 2021 gestimmt hat, ist es ja obvios, dass es 2022
noch nicht passiert oder, logisch, logisch, ist ja klar, es wäre uns viel zu schnell,
hast du Lost Ark angeschaut, ja aber nicht gespielt, angeschaut schon, ich weiß nicht
ob sich das für mich lohnt, weil ich bin so beschäftigt, alles mögliche plus ein MMO
grinden, schon, weiß nicht ob ich ein zweites MMO grinden kann, wahrscheinlich nicht, lass
uns Jibane von Level Cap am Anfang würde ich sagen, fail to ban alternative, ne, oh ich
hab Mods, ich brauch kein fail to ban, komm in die Gruppe, Leute jetzt, ich sag nie was
zu Corona, aber ich muss mal eine Sache jetzt loswerden, hat nix direkt mit Corona zu tun,
was mich persönlich sehr verwirrt hat beziehungsweise bisschen nachdenklich gemacht hat und zwar
ich hab letztens wieder alte Musik von den Ärzten gehört, so und die Ärzte gehen ja
so Richtung Punk Rock und wenn man sich die Texte mal anhört und denkt die kämen aus
der heutigen Zeit, da geht es zum größten Teil um, keine Ahnung, so gegen das System,
Freiheit für alle, gegen den Strom schwimmen und so Dinger, was halt so in Punk Rock Texten
vorkommt.
Also wenn ich mir diese Texte anhöre und wende das mal an auf aktuelle Corona Geschichten,
dann frag ich mich weiterhin, warum ist alles rechts was was an Corona kritisiert?
Wisst ihr wie ich mein, ich will nicht ausschließen, ich will nicht mal bestreiten, dass es da
nicht sogar einige gibt, aber ich glaube eher, dass sich in dieser ganzen Querdenker Geschichte
einfach alle Leute tummeln, die jetzt einen gemeinsamen Nenner gefunden haben, dass man
so pauschal sagen kann, die sind alle rechts, glaube ich nicht, ich würde sagen, man kann
pauschal sagen, dass die meisten davon irgendeinen Knall haben, das kann man sicherlich sagen.
Aber es hat mich doch echt verwundert, da habe ich mir so überlegt, so irgendwie so
der 90er Jahre Punk, der sich vielleicht noch damals an irgendwelche Gleisen gekettet hat
bei einem Atomtransport, bei einem, das war ja kein Atomtransport, das war so ein Endlager
oder so Transport, also die Leute, die sich damals dann auch noch in Frankfurt hingestellt
haben und gesagt haben, nieder mit dem Kapitalismus und bla bla bla, also wenn du zu denen damals
gegangen wärst und hättest gesagt, hättest gesagt, ey, du, lass dich impfen und der hätte
dich gefragt, warum, du sagst ja, weil es sinnvoll ist und weil der Staat das sagt,
dann hätte er gesagt, fick den Staat, leck mich und hätte dir eine reingehauen, also
und diese Leute kannst du nur wirklich nicht sagen, dass sie in irgendeiner Art und Weise
rechts wären, allein schon wenn du dem gesagt hättest, oder wenn du sagst, ja, dann verdient
vielleicht noch irgendein Impfding Geld damit, der hätte dir eine reingehauen wahrscheinlich,
also so diese pauschale Sache nach dem Motto, alles was da irgendwie da kritisiert ist rechts,
weiß ich nicht, ob das zutrifft, ich glaube das ist deutlich zu einfach, naja gut, Wort
zum Sonntag, jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an, ich weiß ja, dass das ein unangenehmes
Thema ist, da redet ja keiner mehr gerne drüber, egal, egal, welcher, soll ich sagen, welche
Ansichten man da verdritt, eigentlich will ich da nur noch die Ruhe davon haben, früher
war alles besser, früher war vieles anders, also eine Sache, da muss ich sagen, wisst
ihr was früher wirklich besser war, also zumindest meiner Ansicht nach, was früher wirklich
besser war, ich kann euch jetzt die Musik nicht zeigen, aber nur so, weil ich selbst
da war, ja, ich kann jetzt, wir können jetzt leider die Musik nicht anmachen, so, guckt
euch mal an, Linkin Park Rock am Ring, und jetzt passt mal auf, guckt mal die Fans an,
da hat keiner ein Handy in der Hand, ja ich bin da auch irgendwo hier, auf diesem Kamerashot
jetzt drauf oder so, guckt euch mal an, das sieht einfach aus, wie aus einer komplett
anderen Zeit, ich meine es ist 16, 18 Jahre her, natürlich, aber guckt euch mal die Fans
an, guckt euch mal, die gucken sich das wirklich an, heute gucken sich die meisten Leute das
nur noch an über den Umweg von ihrem Smartphone Bildschirm, ich kann keinen Ton machen, weil
sonst Copyright Probleme, das ist schon, das ist wirklich komplett andere Welt, aber man
muss sagen, irgendwie sahen die Leute da auch deutlich unbeschwerter aus, ich muss eh sagen,
ich glaube, ich hatte die beste, ich glaube, ich bin in der besten Zeit geboren, und ich
glaube, das denken tatsächlich die wenigsten von sich, jeder ist irgendwie so immer am
meckern, so nach dem Motto, ah, das ist da doof und hier doof, aber ich glaube, ich bin
in der besten Zeit geboren, ich bin 1984 geboren, das heißt, ich habe komplett, sag mal mal
so die klassische Kindheit noch gehabt, so ohne Computer und irgendwie Internet und sonst
was, also ich war dann, auch wie ich jung war, mit Freunden draußen, hab gespielt und sonst
was, ich hab das mitgekriegt und ich hab komplett von Anfang an Computer daheim und Internetsachen
mitgekriegt, also ich hatte quasi so halbe halbe, sagen wir mal so bis 12, 13, hatte
ich so normale Kindheit und, ja gut, bis 16, 16, eher so bis 97, 98, weiß man, da kam
ich am Hafen, also irgendwie 96, 97 rum, dann hat er Computerzeug angefangen, also 12,
13, ja kommt doch hin, 12, 13, ich glaube nicht, dass jeder denkt, dass er in der besten
Zeit geboren ist, ich glaube, die meisten finden irgendwas kacke, ja, genau, und dann
hatte ich Computerzeug, Internet, hab ich komplett mitgekriegt, ich weiß noch, wie
wir, wie mein Vater drei Monate mit der Telekom telefoniert hat, weil die es immer noch nicht
geschafft haben, den DSL-Anschluss zu schalten, wir hatten den ersten oder einen der ersten
DSL-Anschlüsse im Ort und die Telekom hat es nicht gebacken bekommen, also Sachen waren
damals schon so wie heute.
Und wisst ihr eine Sache, die an den 90ern wirklich gut war, über so Sachen wie Konzerte
ohne Handys und so kann man streiten, aber, okay zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen, erstens, dass
noch nicht jeder der Ansicht war, dass irgendwie seine Probleme die Welt interessieren müssen,
das ist ja heute so, Shitstorms in der Form gab es noch nicht, aber okay, das ist das
eine, aber das wirklich beste an den 90ern, es ist so allgemein, dass den Leuten so viel
am Arsch vorbeiging, es hat sich in den 90ern eigentlich keiner großartig irgendwie Sorgen
gemacht.
Wisst ihr wie ich mein, heute hast du ja an jeder Ecke irgendwas, klar, da gab es in
der Welt auch riesige Probleme in den 90ern, das ist keine Frage, aber ich beziehe das
jetzt ja auf uns hier und ja natürlich hatten die Leute da genau ähnliche Probleme wie
heute, es gab Leute die waren arbeitslos, es gab Leute die hatten so wenig Geld, es
gab alles, aber nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen, die Leute haben die Leute vom Aldi
gecampt um ein Median-PC zu bekommen, man muss aber echt sagen, die Leute waren viel
entspannter, ja nennt man das, die haben sich nicht so reingesteigert, die waren eigentlich
einfach zum größten Teil, war denen die Welt egal, gelassener ja, sorgenloser triffts,
sorgloser triffts ganz gut, die Leute waren deutlich sorgloser, heute ist ja jeder zweiten
Tag irgendein neues Drama, sorgloser triffts, triffts eigentlich ganz gut, natürlich kann
man jetzt argumentieren sagen, hey die ganzen Umweltprobleme die wir heute haben liegen
mit daran, dass man in 90ern sorglos war, ok ja, aber man war's und so ein paar Sachen
die ich mir vorgestellt habe, wie geil die Sachen in Zukunft werden, wurden nicht wirklich
geil, zum Beispiel habe ich mir so in den so 2000 rum dann so vorgestellt, also die ersten
MMOs aufgekommen sind und so was, habe ich mir vorgestellt, boah, muss das mal geil sein,
wie, wo sind denn SMM, oder ganz einfach, die meisten von euch haben vielleicht, oder
viele von euch haben wahrscheinlich am Anfang auch ein bisschen World of Warcraft gespielt,
das war nicht so mein Game muss ich sagen, aber ich glaube, das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel,
weil die meisten Leute das kennen und da haben sich bestimmt viele auch gedacht, man ist
zweiter, wann kam das raus, 2005 oder so, gell, so nach dem Motto, boah, alter, wenn die Games
2005 schon so geil sind, stellt euch mal vor, wo sind MMOs erst 2020, also man hat damals
gedacht, MMOs ist das Ding, was in 20 Jahren, in 15, 20 Jahren einfach nur noch viel größer,
noch viel geiler, noch viel besser ist, dann guckt euch MMOs heute an, es ist ja fast nur
noch scheiße, das hätte ich nicht gedacht damals, dass die ersten MMOs mit die besten
sind, wieso soll man auch davon ausgehen, naja, und was ich auch gedacht habe damals,
was ich auch nicht so wirklich bewahrheitet hat, wie gesagt, ich bin da 1984 geboren,
das heißt, ich habe die Zeit so vor Internet und Computern daheim mitgekriegt und dann
auch komplett von Anfang an mit und ich dachte mir, weil damals haben sich alle Lehrer schwer
getan in der Schule mit, die Eltern haben sich schwer getan damit, die anderen Leute
in der Schule, also die Mitschüler und so haben sich alle mit Computer, also in meinem
Alter die Leute haben sich schwer getan mit Computerzeug und so und ich dachte mir so,
ey, okay, 2020, weiß nicht, ob ich wirklich an 2020 gedacht habe, aber so in die Richtung
von 2020 ist es dann so standard mittlerweile, dann sind die alten Lehrer weg, die neuen
blicken durch und die jungen Leute wachsen damit auf und haben eigentlich überhaupt
keinerlei Berührungsprobleme mehr mit Technik, dann muss ich sagen, das ist nicht so geworden,
die Lehrer heute haben immer noch keine Ahnung von Technik, es gibt immer noch Lehrer mit
Overhead-Projektor oder die Hilfe von den Schülern brauchen, um den Fernseher irgendwie
anzuschließen oder so oder YouTube aufzumachen, keine Ahnung, also, wäre immer noch keine
Ahnung, die Leute in meinem Alter haben nach wie vor keine Ahnung zum größten Teil und
noch viel schlimmer, die jüngeren Leute, wo ich eigentlich immer gedacht habe, alter,
die blicken da instinktiv durch, die haben auch keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, da liegt
das daran, dass man heute, also früher war es so, es war zu komplex, dass man sich damit
beschäftigen wollte, so nach dem Motto, wie soll ich meine Oma erklären mit einem DSL-Moder
im daheim, also sprich, meine Oma hatte keinen Bock drauf gehabt, weil es zu neu war und
zu komplex, sich damit zu beschäftigen oder meine Mutter oder mein Vater oder so, heute
ist es umgedreht, die Leute, die quasi mit ihrem Smartphone aufgewachsen sind, für die
muss der Scheiß einfach quasi App Store aufmachen, runterladen, funktionieren oder sie nehmen
die nächste App, also im Prinzip ist es da genau umgedreht, jetzt muss es quasi, jetzt
erwartet man, dass es einfach geht, also es ist vieles quasi schon zu einfach, als dass
man sich damit beschäftigen möchte, was die Hintergründe sind, gibt es was zu deinem HP
Microserver hier im Stream, ne würde ich nie streamen, ich weiß nicht, ich hab gestern
4,5 Stunden dazu gestreamt, was soll ich noch machen, aber das verwundert mich heute noch,
dass immer noch durch die Bankwerk in jeder Generation die Leute von Technik keine Ahnung
haben, Elect Critical Information, also wie gesagt, ältere haben heute keine Ahnung von
Technik, Leute in meinem Alter haben immer noch keine Ahnung und jüngere, die eigentlich
damit aufgewachsen sind, haben auch keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert,
also muss ich sagen, mein Beruf ist gesichert bis zur Rente, wobei ich nicht bis 67 arbeiten
vorhabe zu arbeiten, naja, gut, was heißt 67, wenn ich in Renike, ist es wahrscheinlich
dann irgendwie 75 oder so, jeder hat halt Stärken und Schwächen, tja, ist halt die
Sache, Sachen die so allgegenwärtig sind, wie dass man zum Beispiel ein bisschen Ahnung
hat, wie das Internet funktioniert, man muss ja nicht das im Detail wissen, man muss ja
nicht wissen, irgendwelche Routing-Protokolle und sonst was, ja, aber so Dinger wie, an
welchen Stecker stecke ich meinen Router und dass nicht das Internet kaputt ist, wenn ich
an meinem Rechner im Browser nichts öffnen kann, das sind so naheliegende Sachen, wo
ich eigentlich gedacht hätte, das hat 2022 jeder verstanden, ja, das ist aber ein Unterschied,
du musst ja auch keinen Computer bauen können, du musst auch keine Teile zusammenlöten
können, aber du weißt auch über dein Auto, wahrscheinlich zumindest, über dein Auto
zumindest so grob Bescheid, aus was es besteht und so ungefähr wie es funktioniert.
Internet kommt doch aus dem HDMI, ja, das ist schlimm, das denken Leute halt wirklich,
die stöpseln HDMI an den Fernseher und sagen, ja und, geht jetzt Internet, und das sind
so Sachen, da habe ich mir gedacht, das muss man 2022 den Leuten sicherlich nicht mehr
erklären, aber anscheinend ist es immer noch so, ja ja, das geht, das geht, theoretisch
geht das, theoretisch kannst du Netzwerkzeuge über HDMI machen, ich glaube über Displayport
auch oder, weißt du, über HDMI geht es auf jeden Fall, so, jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein
bisschen was an, also, wir lassen uns am Anfang wieder von LevelCapture baiten würde ich sagen,
was zur Hölle, Battlefield, oh Gott, Alexibexy, es gibt so ein paar Channels im deutschsprachigen
YouTube, ich kann es mir einfach nicht geben, schön, wem es gefällt, aber es muss ja nicht
jeder alles mögen, und Alexibexy kann ich mir echt nicht angucken, geht mit meinem Zeug
eigentlich auch vielen so, was verdient ein Dachdecker, das finde ich nicht genug,
der Stuhl soll bequem sein, oh, weiß ja nicht, ja die kriegen es ja nicht gebacken ihren
Battlefield 3 Project Reality rauszubringen mal, das sollte ja schon für über einem
Jahr rauskommen, ach ja, Moment, wo wir dabei sind, das müssen wir gerade mal kurz gucken,
Steam Stats New World, Steam Stats Battlefield, das ist immer Tradition mittlerweile schon,
das wird ja immer schlechter, das wird ja immer schlechter, hast du schon die neuen
Leaks von Charlie Intel gesehen, du meinst zu MW2, ne, aber ich weiß, dass es die gibt,
ich muss sagen, ich bin eh der Meinung, man kann sicherlich sagen, Modern Warfare 2019
war an sich kein schlechtes Game, also es gibt ja genug, denen das gefallen hat, ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen, dass MW2 2022 auch durchaus brauchbar wird, aber für mich ist
das eine komplette Bankrotterklärung an die Kreativität, also der Reboot an sich schon
und die Fortsetzung des Reboots noch mehr, für die ist es natürlich super, die können
neue Leute abgreifen und die alten Fans cashen auch wieder rein, weil sie damit gute Sachen
verbinden.
Da könnte ich eigentlich mal ein Video zumachen, so Modern Warfare 2 2022 irgendwie, ja, könnt
ihr euch mal ein Video zumachen, ok zumindest, also Battlefield Spielerzahlen sind ja absolut
all time low, du musst es erstmal schaffen, 60-60-35, da ist ja fast nichts mehr übrig,
es soll irgendwie, sag mal habt ihr das verfolgt, jetzt wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich hab nur
am Rande gelesen, dass es in Modern Warfare 2 sowas wie Portal geben soll, oder warte
hab ich das falsch interpretiert, es soll ja irgendwie noch einen dritten Spielmodus
geben, irgendwie DMZ oder sowas, ok wisst ihr auch nicht Bescheid, ist auch egal, so
spannend find ich euch, so und jetzt Trommelwirbel New World Zahlen für diese Woche, oh Gott
das wird ja immer schlechter, die sind jetzt ja schon bei unter, die haben ja die Hälfte
von der Hälfte erreicht mittlerweile, letztens waren die erst noch bei 90.000, jetzt sind
die bei der Hälfte, die stellen das doch bald ein oder, das ist doch, ich mein, ein
Spiel hat ja kein Abo-Modell im klassischen Sinn, ähm, die müssen ja irgendwelchen Kram
verkaufen, bald lohnt sich das doch überhaupt nicht mehr, ein großes Entwicklerteam dafür
hinzustellen und überhaupt neue Sachen zu entwickeln, wenn das eh niemand sieht.
Welches Game trendet, können wir mal gucken, welches Game trendet denn aktuell, Lost Ark,
CS, Dota, Apex, GTA, Rust, das find ich witzig, so ok, was gucken wir uns jetzt an, Budget
and Home Server Build, können wir uns nachher irgendwann angucken, ok, also wir lassen uns
mal eine Runde von LevelCapture Baiten, eine Runde LevelCapture Baiten Leute, jetzt mal,
ihr habt das ja wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, aber es gibt eine Petition, dass Battlefield
2042 Käufer das Geld zurückerstattet bekommen, was meint ihr, wieviel Aussichten auf Erfolg
diese Petition so hat, ratet mal, minus Null, ja, kommt ungefähr hin, ganz im Ernst, ich
weiß nicht, wie die Leute sich das vorstellen, es ist jetzt nicht irgendeine, was weiß ich,
irgendeine Regierungstagungsgeschichte, wo man bei so und so viel Unterschriften sich
dann das als Agenda auf den Tagesprogramm bringen muss oder so, das ist ein, wie soll
ich sagen, die sind ja in keinster Weise, nur weil es da eine Petition gibt, zu irgendwie
auch nur einem Zwinkern verpflichtet, ja, nichts, warum sollten die das machen, das Game hat
jetzt schon mit Sicherheit nicht das reingebracht, was es gekostet hat, das Game hat ja insgesamt,
was weiß ich, an die 2 Milliarden gekostet, das ist krass, also Battlefield 2042 insgesamt
war mega teuer und was da rausgekommen ist halt der Witz, blöde Frage, ist Vulcan so
schwer in eine Engine zu integrieren oder die meisten zu faul, keine Ahnung, ich kenne
mich mit Vulcan nicht aus, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es, dass das Schwierige ist, es
in eine Engine zu integrieren, weil egal, ob du jetzt OpenGL nimmst, DirectX, Vulcan,
Metal oder was auch immer, das ist ja nicht wirklich Bestandteil der eigentlichen Engine,
die man verwendet, um ein Spiel zu erstellen, sondern das sind die Rendering Layer unten
drunter, wahrscheinlich ist Vulcan so komplex, dass es schwierig ist, einen neuen Rendering
Layer für Vulcan zu bauen, worauf dann, oder was man als Target für die eigentliche Engine
verwenden könnte, weil Vulcan wahrscheinlich unglaublich komplex und kompliziert ist, wobei
ich glaube Unity hat doch sogar ein Vulcan Target, oder? Itami, danke für den Sub. Was
ich momentan spiele, ich spiele Oldschool MMOs, Kreiselgrind. So, wir gucken jetzt
erstmal fertig hier. Oh nein, Leute, ich muss doch was sagen, jetzt hole ich gerade hier
die Herr der Ringe Auszüge gesehen habe. Habt ihr die ersten Bilder von der Amazon Herr
der Ringe Serie gesehen? Das erste, was ich mir gedacht habe ist, das waren so meine ersten
Gedanken davon, ganz schlimm. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, achso, ja, übrigens, das muss
man ja heutzutage dabei sagen, ich störe mich nicht darin, dass ich schwarze Darsteller
als Zwergen habe oder so, können wir machen, was wir wollen. Das ist mir vollkommen egal.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, wenn sie sich schon für eine Zeit entschieden haben, was
vorher der Ringe spielt, es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es da nicht genug, wie soll man
sagen, Original Material und Charaktere und Geschichten, die man aufgreifen könnte, aber
nein, man verfrachtet das in eine theoretische Zeit vor Herr der Ringe, also in einer Zeitlinie,
wo es nicht so viel spannendes gibt drum herum und er findet neue Charaktere, er findet
neue Handlungen. Warum? Wenn man eine Herr der Ringe Serie macht bzw. eine Mittelerde
Serie, warum nimmt man da nicht Storys, wo sich die Leute schon seit Jahren wünschen,
das mal auf einen größeren Stil zu sehen, anstatt, was interessieren mich irgendwelche
neue Charaktere, who cares, nicht, dass man das nicht gut machen kann, aber wenn man doch,
aber wenn man doch, sagen wir mal, neue Charaktere will, neue Geschichten will, warum muss es
dann überhaupt in Mittelerde spielen? Ich habe noch nicht mal was dagegen, wenn man
jetzt Sachen nimmt und dann drum herum noch ein bisschen was strikt um die Kernhandlung,
aber warum nimmt man nicht von den tausend Sachen was, die schon da sind? Ihr das Problem
ist, es mag jetzt sein, dass Tolkien das gesagt hat, aber wie man gesehen hat, z.B. auch an
der Rad der Zeitserie, kriegen sie es ja nicht gebacken, das mit sinnvollen Sachen zu füllen.
Da haben sie sich sogar noch an die Story gehalten. Oder auch die Witcher Serie, ich weiß nicht,
also ich habe den zweiten Teil noch nicht geguckt, ich beziehe mich auf die erste Season,
das war okay, aber das hat mich jetzt nicht irgendwie in Begeisterung versetzt. Irgendwie
verstehe ich es nicht, also gerade wenn man die Lizenz dafür hat, Herr der Ringe Sachen
zu machen oder Sachen im Mittelerdeuniversum zu machen, was meiner Ansicht nach heute,
obwohl es mittlerweile viel viel mehr Fantasy Sachen und sonst was gibt, immer noch mit
zum besten Fantasy Welt, durchdachtesten Fantasy Welt überhaupt gehört, warum nimmt man da
nicht irgendwas, was halt schon da ist und ausgearbeitet ist und reinpasst, anstatt sich
neues Zeug auszudenken? Das verstehe ich nicht, zumal die sich ja in den letzten Jahren nicht
mit Ruhm bekleckert haben, sich neue Sachen auszudenken. Ja und außerdem hat mir das
nicht gefallen, was man gesehen hat. Okay, aber das fällt mir nur gerade dazu ein, also
das habe ich keine großen Hoffnungen drinne. Naja, nicht wirklich, an dem Spiel hat sich
ja nichts geändert.
Zuletzt hat sich die Community-Ren-Petition auf Change.org über 150.000 Signaturen von
Spielern ausgemacht. Das macht sich der EA-CEO am Montag auf und macht einmal kurz
Spaß auf dem Spiel, egal welches ihre preferente Plattform ist. Die Petition hat sehr wenig
Aufmerksamkeit vor ein paar Wochen, als sie erst erst erstellt wurde, jedoch in den letzten
wenigen Tagen hat die Community online es über verschiedene soziale Kanäle geteilt,
mit der Hoffnung, dass es eine Veränderung zu den Betreffenden der EA-Petition auf zukünftige
Produkte bringen wird.
Seltsam ist, dass die originale Petition-Deskription gesagt hat, dass ein erfahrener Arzt sich mit
der Bewegung mit 50.000 Signaturen anbieten würde, aber nun sieht es aus, dass es in
Fakt kein Arzt mehr ist, der bereit ist, den Fall aufzunehmen.
Auf der anderen Seite sieht es aus, als wäre der Betreffender hinter der Petition unter
einem falschen Namen. Es sieht sehr unwahrscheinlich aus, dass diese Petition eigentlich
keine Art von legaler Aktion ist. Wenn es um die Refund-Polizei von verschiedenen
Retail-Plattformen geht, werden sie jeweils zu einigen Gründen unterschiedlich. Und die
Läden hinter der Digital-Gut-Refundung bedarf sogar von dem Land, in dem ihr lebt.
Für PlayStation schließt die Refund-Window auf, wenn ihr den Download startet, wenn
das Spiel falsch ist. Für Microsoft dauert die Refund-Window so lange, dass ihr nicht
eine bedeutende Anzahl an Spielzeit akumuliert. Und wenn es ums EA geht, ist die Refund-Window
mehr oder weniger 24 Stunden seit dem Verkaufs-Datei oder zumindest dem Launch-Datei des Spiels.
Viele Spieler würden argumentieren, dass Battlefield 2042 falsch ist, also fällt es unter
einigen besonderen Situationen, in denen Spieler sogar außerhalb der typischen Refund-Periode
erhebbar sein sollten. Und natürlich ist all das sehr interessant, aber ich würde
mir vorstellen, dass EA wahrscheinlich nur weiter tun wird, was sie schon gemacht haben,
das ist, Refund auf eine Fall-bei-Fall-Base zu erheben. In anderen Battlefield 2042-News
Players sind wieder aufgeregt über die neuen Kosmetik-Items, die zu dem Spiel werden, und
in diesem Fall ist es die Taktikale Beanie-Kosmetik-Reward für das Spiel.
Okay, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Das ist ein Epic Headgear. Ein Hütchen. Oder Kappe. Dann
doch lieber... Dann doch lieber Halo Infinite Katzenohren, oder? Also was ist mehr Epic?
Halo Infinite Katzenohren oder das Beanie für Angel? Nein. Das ist doch Schwachsinn. Das
ist einfach ne fucking Mütze, ich hab auch so eine, die sieht genauso aus. Und ich sag
nicht, haha, ich trage die Mütze von Haggard aus Bad Company 2. Das ist die Mütze, die
sehen halt nur mal so aus. Ja, einer der Weiß-Supporter spricht. Ja, einer der Weiß-Supporter
spricht. Ja, das hab ich auch gelesen. Was ich viel spannender fand, ist, wo er über
die Maps geschrieben hat, dass sie keine Details haben. Zeig mal, wo steht denn das? Ist das
hier drinnen? Ja, hier. Why are all maps shipping without any detail art? Ja, genau.
Das Game hat keine Details. Das ist tatsächlich ne Frage, die ich mir schon in der langen
Stelle, seit er Beta, warum hat er im Spiel keine Details? Na egal. Ja, das ist die eigentliche
Frage, die ich mich so in die langen Stelle stelle.
Das denke ich, das denke ich auch. Das hab ich auch in meinen Videos gesagt. Das Battlefield
2042 ist durch. Das ist vorbei. Das wirst du nie wieder gerettet bekommen. Aber es wird
nicht das letzte sein, was wir sehen.
Es ist geil. Wir wussten schon seit 2-3 Monaten, dass das rauskommt. Aber jetzt wird offiziell
bestätigt, dass das, was wir schon wussten, wir jetzt wissen.
Leute, Brand New Game Engine. Gab es ein Call of Duty, wo sie das noch nicht erzählt
haben? Das einzige Mal, wo es gestimmt hat war Modern Warfare 2019.
Ah, dann hab ich das falsch verstanden. Ich hab Sandbox Mode gelesen und dachte, das ist
sowas wie Portal. Nee, ist es nicht. Okay.
Microsoft, die in dem Prozess von Call of Duty's Publisher Activision beteiligt sind,
haben mit Sony erlaubt, dass Call of Duty auch auf PlayStation beyond das Existenteam
möglich ist, so dass PlayStation-Spieler weiterhin die Spiele genießen können.
Wunderbar ist, dass Microsoft auch dieselben Schritte mit der Nintendo-Plattform macht.
Call of Duty auf die Nintendo Switch z.B. würde ein ganz neues Markt von Spielern öffnen.
In Gaming-Tech-News, die frühen Reviews für die vorhandenstehende Steam-Deck-Valve haben
mit vielen Enthusiastinnen die Hardware- und Software-Experienzen eröffnet worden sind.
Obwohl Epic Games-CEO Tim Sweeney etwas weniger glücklicher hat,
ist es schwer, etwas zu sagen. According to Sweeney, Epic Games currently doesn't plan to update
Fortnite so that it can run on SteamOS, the operating system used on the Steam Deck. In
order to play Fortnite on the Steam Deck, you would need to install Windows on the device.
The reasoning behind this is pretty strange. Sweeney said the company doesn't feel confident
in its own easy anti-cheat service, despite it being supported on Linux, the basis that
SteamOS is built upon. It's tough to say if this will have any meaningful impact on
the Steam Deck's success. Exact three order numbers are hard to come by, but we do know
that over 100,000 units were pre-ordered just three hours after it went on sale. Chances
are it'll do just fine without one of the world's most popular titles. More than 240
games have received their Steam Deck Verified badge, meaning that they are optimized to
run more efficiently on the new hardware. Hundreds, if not thousands of others, should
also work just fine. So it's not like Steam Deck users are missing tons of games.
Bestes Game! Ich muss sagen, Factorio ist eines der besten Games, die ich die letzten Jahre
über so entdeckt habe. Also Factorio ist echt ein Game, das fängst du an und dann
guckst du raus und sagst, oh, es ist ja schon dunkel.
Resident Evil 4 Remake? Moment, Resident Evil 4 ist glaube ich eines der am öftesten
releasen und gedingsten. Ok, Resident Evil 1 haben sie auch schon. Aber Resident Evil
4 kam doch ins, gibt es doch schon fünf verschiedene Varianten für 100 verschiedene Hardwares?
Resident Evil 4 Original. A lot of the inspiration for this reimagined vision of the game spawns
from the scrapped demos from before. The original game's demos were pretty experimental with
the Resident Evil formula and certainly struck a much deeper vibe compared to what actually
shifts. Apparently portions of the remake now take place at night areas. Side characters
and storylines have been further refined and fleshed out to make the game a richer experience.
Rumour has it that this Resident Evil 4 Remake will be revealed sometime this year, so hopefully
we won't have to wait much longer. This remake is supposedly being helmed by the team that
worked on the Resident Evil 2 Remake, which received major praise from players and critics.
J.R.R. Tolkien's The Lord of the Rings Movie, Gaming and Merchandising rights are about
to go on sale. The current owner, Saul Zenzko, has elected to sell its stake in the properties
which will no doubt bring in plenty of potential buyers. The auctions are scheduled for this
week with some properties being evaluated at up to 2 billion dollars. According to numerous
reports, Amazon is one of the prime contenders to buy up these rights after already forking
over 250 million dollars to produce its new TV show, The Rings of Power.
Gaming, Daedalic Entertainment is already working on a new title based on Golem, while The Lord
of the Rings Online MMO is continuing to receive updates. Depending on who buys the rights,
there's no way of telling what potential gaming content may come from this deal.
Nintendo held their Nintendo Direct Presentation this week, where plenty of games were shown
off and announced. Some of the biggest announcements include No Man's Sky, Coming to Switch, Splatoon
3, Nintendo Switch, Sports and Mario Kart 8 Deluxe, a version of the game featuring remastered
courses from across the series as paid DLC. These courses can be accessed through the
Booster Course Pass, which will deliver a total of 48 remastered courses by the end of
next year.
Just before we get onto our final story of the day, why not tell us your thoughts on
the Battlefield 2042 Refund Petition? Do you think the EA should and will make a special
exception to the rule?
Under these circumstances, we would love to know what you think in the comments. A new
Assassin's Creed game is in development and this is actually the second game in the franchise
that is expected to launch in the near future.
You know what they could do? They could make a God of War crossover with a DLC. The next
God of War is not that far away anymore, at least you already know the title. I mean,
it plays in the same regions, though in a completely different dimension, but why not?
In the future, as another game by the name of Assassin's Creed Infinity will change up
the game with multiple settings and characters while this other game started as an expansion
for Assassin's Creed Valhalla. Codenamed Assassin's Creed Rift, this game was shifted
from being an expansion to Valhalla and into its own standalone game last year. It'll
supposedly feature one of the characters from Valhalla, Basim, and will be smaller in scope
compared to the previous games in the franchise. Apparently, it'll focus on stealthy gameplay
over the next few years.
Odyssey. So maybe this will please some veteran fans who have longed for a return to the more
stealth-oriented gameplay of the old titles. According to one report, the game will...
Mal ernsthaft, Assassin's Creed, auch wenn es immer so getan hat, war nie ein Stealth-Game.
Es hatte... es sah so aus, aber du musstest quasi nie schleichen. Es gab einzelne Missionen,
wo du nicht gesehen werden durftest und sowas. Aber Assassin's Creed ist glaube ich das unstealthigste
Stealth-Game, was es gibt.
Now we know.
Gibt es jetzt Upload... ah, das gucken wir uns gleich hinterher an. Gibt es jetzt Uploadfilter
oder nicht? Tja, das ist eine gute Frage. Insgesamt würde ich sagen, ja, klar gibt's
die. Deswegen wird mittlerweile auch so viel forschnell auf YouTube und überall gesperrt.
Weil die so einen Schiss haben, irgendwie haften zu müssen. Aber gucken wir mal.
Nach ziemlich genau einem Jahr habe ich die Zeit zwischen dem Beschluss der neuen EU-Urheberrechtsreform
bis Anfang 2021 zurückverfolgt und musste damals zwangsläufig auf einer ernüchternden
Note enden, denn schließlich war damals noch vieles unsicher. Doch heute, ein Jahr später,
ist das immer noch so. Aber nicht ganz so sehr wie letztes Mal. Deswegen hier die Zeitlinie
von Januar 2021 bis heute.
Wir erinnern uns, in der letzten Episode hat von allen Ländern ausgerechnet Polen gegen
die EU geklagt und die Aufhebung von Artikel 17 mit Uploadfiltern und Co. gefordert. 2020
gab's eine erste Anhörung der Argumente, die Entscheidung sollte aber erst 2021 fallen.
Jetzt mal eine Frage. Warum dauert der ganze Scheiß immer so extrem lange alles? Warum
sind das immer bürokratisches Gewichtheben mit 5000 involvierten Leuten? Warum dauert
das alles immer so ewig?
Wie üblich diskutiert, aktuelle Versionen der Texte veröffentlicht und Feedback gesammelt
und alles lief auf den 1. August 2021 hinaus. Dem Datum, ab dem das alles in Deutschland
gelten soll. Im März 2021 wird das Gesetz auch erstmals groß im Bundestag diskutiert.
Dabei werden unter anderem die Regelungen für den Gebrauch von Ausschnitten aus Sportübertragungen
verschärft, aber auch der Beschwerdemechanismus konkretisiert und das Risiko für Overblocking
dabei verringert. Es wird auch beschlossen, dass große Rechteinhaber einen metaphorischen
roten Knopf besitzen sollen, mit dem sie in Extremfällen Verwendung ihrer eigenen Werke
sofort und unverzüglich sperren lassen können. Auch wird ein sogenanntes Verbandsklage-
Angeblich soll's ja sogar so sein, wenn die diesen roten Knopf dann zu oft missbrauchen
soll, was passieren. Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Recht im Gesetz implementiert, was sich Vereinen und Verbänden erlaubt, stellvertretend für
andere gegen einen Verstoß des Gesetzes klagen zu dürfen.
Dann vergehen vier lange Monate, bis sich der zuständige Generalanwalt des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs räuspert. Er hat die Argumente von Polen abgeweckt und eine Verletzung der
EU-Charta für Grundrechte durch Artikel 17 geprüft. Das Ergebnis? Nö, alles Paletti,
solange auch wirklich keine legalen Inhalte gesperrt werden. Er sieht zwar eine potenzielle
Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit.
Nein, das wird ja nie vorkommen, dass illegale Inhalte gesperrt werden. Nein, das kann ja
gar nicht sein. Wir definieren jetzt einfach weg, dass das passieren kann.
Aber in keinem Ausmaß, dass eine Verletzung der Grundrechte darstellen würde. Er empfiehlt,
dass Uploadfilter für eine grundrechtskonforme Anwendung ausschließlich megaoffensichtliche
Rechtsverletzung sperren sollten. Wenn Corbinian mal wieder versucht, Spy Kids 3D auf Vimeo
hochzuladen zum Beispiel.
Er bemängelt auch, dass das Gesetz zwar Alternativen der Inhaltefilterung ermöglicht, aber nicht
Alternativen zur Inhaltefilterung. Die Gefahr des Overblockings sieht er aufgrund der von
einigen Länder unerarbeiteten Vorsichtsmaßnahmen als minimiert und empfiehlt, die Klage von
Polen abzuweisen. Mehr kann er aber auch nicht tun. Das ist kein Urteil, sondern nur eine
Empfehlung, der der Europäische Gerichtshof folgen kann, aber nicht muss. Auch wenn er
das meist tut.
Wie das Gericht auch entscheidet, die Chance ist nicht gerade gering, dass in jedem Fall
einige nationale Umsetzungen der Richtlinie gekippt werden, die keine genügenden Maßnahmen
gegen Overblocking in ihren Gesetzestext implementiert haben. Deutschland wird aber wahrscheinlich
nicht dazu gehören.
Dann folgt der große Tag. Der 1. August. Der Tag, an dem das Internet endete.
Artikel 17 tritt in Deutschland in Kraft und es passiert wenig. Der Spiegel hat im Zuge
dessen die größten Social-Media-Plattformen gefragt, wie sie gedenken, das Gesetz in
Deutschland umzusetzen. TikTok antwortet erst gar nicht. Facebook verweist einfach
auf sein schon bestehendes Meldesystem und Twitch vermeidet nervös den Blickkontakt
und sagt, ja, wir machen das so, wie das Gesetz es sagt.
YouTube antwortet als einzige Plattform ausführlich, was das erste Mal ist, dass ich das sage.
Das stimmt wohl.
Man verweist auf eine Erweiterung des Content-ID-Systems, der Software, die bereits vor Einführung
von Artikel 17 sämtliche Uploads nach unzulässigen Inhalten durchsucht hat. Man implementiert
das vorgeschriebene Pre-Flagging-Tool, das jedoch nur zum Tragen kommt, wenn der hauseigene
Upload-Filter auch wirklich etwas zu beanstanden hat. Außerdem verweist man auf die Weiterentwicklung
des sogenannten Copyright-Match-Tools, das veröffentlichte Inhalte auf YouTube nachzuforgestehen.
Wie gut das funktioniert, sieht man zum Beispiel, dass Semper-Videos Sachen gelöscht werden.
... Inhalte durchsucht, um diese ebenfalls runterzunehmen.
Nicht wegen Copyrights, sondern weil Hacking-Content.
... Upload-Filter erkannt werden, wird darüber oft noch während des Uploads informiert und
muss sich entscheiden, sich via Pre-Flagging auf Parodie oder anderweitig erlaubte Nutzungsräume
zu berufen oder den Upload abzubrechen.
Ebenfalls am 1. August verkündet der Verein Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte von dem zuvor
erwirkten Verbandskraft...
Was von denen gelöscht wird, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, er hat insgesamt, nachdem er
Probleme mit ein paar Videos hatte... Ich glaube, haben die nicht bis zu ein Drittel
der Videos gelöscht jetzt im Nachhinein?
... Tragerecht Gebrauch machen zu wollen, Vorfälle von Overblocking oder falsch positiven Treffern...
Ey, die kommen irgendwie bekannt vor. War das nicht die Einzige, die damals im... Was
war das? EU-Parlament oder so den alten Säcken mal erklärt hat, was es eigentlich bedeutet,
wenn man das durchwinkt? Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel.
Hat aber keine Sau interessiert damals, Upload-Filter anzuklagen.
Noch sammelt der Verein allerdings und hat noch keine Auskunft über das Ausmaß der
Beschwerden gegeben.
Direkt am Anschluss, am 2. August verkündet David Hain auf seinem YouTube-Kanal aufgrund
der Undurchsichtigkeit über erlaubte oder unerlaubte Nutzung von Filmausschnitten seine
Formate entsprechend anzupassen und nur noch so wenig Ausschnitte aus Filmen zu verwenden
wie möglich.
Sein jüngster Ausbruch aus dieser Limitation hat dann dafür gesorgt, dass das Video direkt
in Deutschland gesperrt wurde.
Na toll.
Am 26.
September wird schließlich ein neuer Bundestag und damit auch eine neue Regierung gewählt.
SPD, FDP und Grüne veröffentlichen Ende November schließlich ihren Koalitionsvertrag, in dem
auch der Satz zum Schutz der Informations- und Meinungsfreiheit-Lehen-wir-verpflichtender
Upload-Filter abfällt.
Na ja, mal gucken.
Es ist ja eh nicht wirklich verbindlich, was da drin steht, das ist halt erstellt worden
und ob das dann...
Ich würde mal ne Auswertung interessieren, wieviel Punkte, sagen wir mal so von den letzten,
was weiß ich, fünf, sechs Regierungen vom Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich wirklich angegangen
wurden.
Schließlich richtig spannend.
Wir als einzelne Nutzer haben keinen großen Überblick über die Auswirkung der Richtlinie
auf das Internet.
Die von einigen herbeigeschriehende YouTube-Apokalypse ist es aber erwartungsgemäß nicht.
YouTube macht dann aber etwas, das sie noch nie gemacht haben.
Also was für mich viel mehr YouTube-Apokalypse ist, ist das Dislike abschaffen.
Sie veröffentlichen Daten über ihr Content-ID-System.
Retrospektiv auf das erste Halbjahr 2021 kann nun nachverfolgt werden, wie viele falsch-positive
Treffer der vermeintlich modernste Upload-Filter der Branche verursacht.
Insgesamt hat Content-ID von Januar bis Juni 2021 722 Millionen Mal angeschlagen, von denen
knapp 3,5 Millionen vermeintliche Urheberrechtsansprüche von den jeweiligen Uploadern angefochten
wurden.
60% dieser Streitfälle wurden zugunsten des jeweiligen Uploaders entschieden.
Also etwas über 2 Millionen Inhalte.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, viele werden sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mit YouTube
da irgendwie diskutieren wollen.
Das sind natürlich nur etwa 0,3% falsch-positive Treffer, aber es sind halt immer noch über
zwei Millionen Videos.
Und in den knapp 3,4 Milliarden Treffern stecken sicherlich auch automatisierte Uploads von
urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalten, die von Bots einfach immer und immer wieder hoch
geladen werden und aber das Verhältnis von positiv zu falsch-positiv aufgrund von Spam
verzerren.
Diese Daten beziehen sich aber auf einen Zeitraum Voreinführung der Gesetze und sind zudem
auch international.
Es bleibt zu hoffen, dass YouTube dieses Jahr Daten für die zweite Jahreshälfte 2021
veröffentlicht, um die realen Auswirkungen von Upload-Filtern auf dieser Plattform
besser nachvollziehen zu können.
Währenddessen wird im Europäischen Parlament über den sogenannten Digital Services Act
diskutiert, eine Art europäisches Meta-Gesetz, das viele Regelungen für den digitalen Raum
europäisch vereinheitlichen soll.
Dort bringt die EVP, zu großen Teilen besetzt mit der CDU-CSU, einen Vorschlag ein, die
doch eh schon beschlossenen Upload-Filter doch auch für die Regulierung weiterer Inhalte,
nicht nur für Urheberrechtsverletzungen, sondern auch für Hassrede und ähnliches
zu verwenden.
Oh ja, Hate Speech, unbedingt.
Kann dir keiner so genau sagen, was Hate Speech eigentlich ist, wo es anfängt und aufhört,
aber unbedingt Hassrede, das geht ja nicht.
Als wäre die Unterscheidung zwischen Parodie und Kopie ja nicht schon technisch unwirklich
genug.
Im späten Januar 2022 wird dieser Vorschlag jedoch abgelehnt, zeigt aber auch, dass jetzt,
wo diese Technologien verpflichtend geworden sind, davon ausgegangen werden muss, dass
immer und immer wieder versucht werden wird, sie für mehr einzusetzen.
Das ist das Problem, warum ich auch prinzipiell immer gegen alles in dieser Richtung bin,
weil es fängt immer an mit ganz extremen Beispielen.
So nach dem Motto, wir machen was gegen Kinderpornografie, wir machen was gegen Mord, Totschlag, Bandenkriminalität,
sonst was.
Es fängt dann immer mit richtig krassen Sachen an, wo niemand was dagegen sagen kann.
Und wenn es dann da ist, dann kommt dann, ja, aber, ja, man könnte das ja auch dafür
verwenden und dann, man könnte es auch dafür und dafür können wir es auch noch und dann,
dann, dann.
So und dann ist es einfach Standard.
Dann ist es einfach normal.
Das wird dann für alles irgendwann, 20 Jahre später wird es für alles verwendet.
Und damit sind wir wieder in der Gegenwart.
Final kann man immer noch nicht sagen, inwiefern die Entschärfung unserer Umsetzung der Richtlinie
wirklich geholfen haben.
Wir sollten uns aber daran gewöhnen, dass Uploadfilter gekommen sind, um zu bleiben
und im schlimmsten Fall auch noch zu wachsen.
Und das ist furchtbar schade.
Deswegen bin ich immer dagegen, wenn es irgendwelche Register einführen wollen, wo irgendwas
drin ist, irgendwelche Sachen Vorratsdaten speichern wollen, irgendwas filtern wollen
oder sonst was.
Das wird ja immer mit, am Anfang mit, wie soll man sagen, so ehrenwerten Zielen vielleicht
verfolgt.
Und ich würde noch nicht mal so weit gehen, dass die Leute, die jetzt dafür sind, das
einzuführen, das in Zukunft missbrauchen wollen, aber vielleicht die, die danach kommen.
Und es wird immer weiter ausgebaut und irgendwann wiegen sie die Scheiße von dir im Klo übertrieben
gesagt.
Also, das ist echt nix, wo ich allzu erfreut darüber bin.
Nix, was kommen wir uns als nächstes an?
10 Home Automations from around the world Part 2.
Da nicht einfach nur, da haben wir den ersten Teil überhaupt geguckt.
Kann ich mich jetzt gar nicht mehr dran erinnern?
Kann ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern?
Was?
Keine Chance für 2022.
Vor 8 Minuten.
Joch, ist mir egal, ich warte, bis das Zeug rauskommt.
Ich mache mir schon lange keine Gedanken mehr um umgelegte Eier, was bei Spielen, was
bei Spielen angeht.
Die wollen unbedingt, dass wir dieses Dachdecker-Video gucken, oder?
Das wird das dritte Mal, dass es vorgestellt wird.
Real Razor Chief ist am Start.
Danke für den Sub.
Denkst du Metafacebook würde wirklich den europäischen Markt aufgehen wegen den Gesetzen?
Das kommt drauf an.
Im Prinzip sind die da sicherlich nicht scharf drauf, weil hier halt viel Kohle zu holen ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn was nicht umsetzbar ist hier, joa, was willst du machen?
Was willst du machen?
Wir werden es schon noch schaffen, dass im Prinzip in EU keiner mehr was machen will.
So, hier gibt es nichts.
Oh, also gucken wir uns die Home-Automation-Ideas an.
Part 2, Five-Hat-Time.
Gucken wir mal, was die Leute da wieder automated haben.
Wow, ich finde das wow klingt aber voll aus Überzeugung.
Wow, Leute, chat.
Chat, ihr seid so geil.
Wow.
Aber die Videos sind trotzdem gut.
Alright, let's get into it.
Starting off first with one of the most hilarious and satisfying automations I've seen.
Liam in Sydney, Australia had a slight cat problem.
They were coming onto the porch and peeing at night.
The cat crossed the line when it decided to pee on Liam's motorbike.
Oh, Anzeige ist raus.
Home Automation.
Warum hat er die Kamera direkt dort, wo die Katze hinpisst?
Now when a cat comes onto the lawn and their camera detects it, a sprinkler automatically
starts up.
Like it does right there.
You can see the cat get drenched.
Take that kitty.
I think it's so funny.
Auf der anderen Seite, ganz ehrlich, das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste, was du machen
kannst, wenn die Katze loswerden willst.
Das tut denen ja nichts.
Liam tried to keep it civil at first by using lavender, mint or ultrasonic sounds to keep
the cats away.
Now the kitties just get a free bath.
Das hat er nachgestellt.
Ah ja, okay.
So how does it exactly work?
Using a home cat automation, when the Arlo Pro 2 camera detects motion, it turns on that
Eve Aqua for the sprinklers.
And this only happens at night.
Das heißt, wenn man irgendjemand durch den Hof läuft, dann wird er erst mal angesprinkelt.
Wisst ihr, was noch viel besser wäre?
Wisst ihr, was noch viel besser wäre, mit Image Detection zu gucken, was das ist?
Das ist mittlerweile erstaunlich gut.
Ich mein, zumindest zwischen Mensch und Nichtmensch kann das Ding, denke ich, relativ gut unterscheiden.
Hat er das nicht gesagt?
Nee, der hat nur gesagt Motion Detection, nicht was es ist.
Warum?
Das ist feifett, Alter.
Das ist feifett.
Ich mein, es ist ja nur die Haustür, es ist ja nicht die Wohnungstür.
Das ist erst mal eine Stufe weniger secure.
Das ist aber feifett, das ist geil.
Ja, ich hab auch Switchbots, okay, Smartwatch ist ziemlich useless, aber okay.
Alternativ kann man einfach, wie bei fast allem anderen, die Home Assistant App verwenden
dafür.
Wisst ihr, wie ich das gemacht hätte?
Wenn ich da vorne ein Schild hätte haben wollen, ob trocken oder nicht, ich hätte
ein ePaper-Display genommen, die Dinger verbrauchen kaum Strom und du musst nichts mechanisch
umschieben, du kannst es einfach quasi ändern, was drauf steht.
Ich hätte wahrscheinlich ein ePaper-Display genommen.
Okay, das ist clever, das ist clever.
Das ist clever, das finde ich gut.
Neonackel-Fahr, danke schön für den Zapp.
Das ist feifett, das ist feifett, dass sie einräumen, ja, das ist feifett.
Das ist feifett, das ist feifett, dass sie einräumen, ja, das ist feifett, das ist feifett.
Ja, Pressure Sensor habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob ich mir nicht ein und das Bett
machen soll.
Ich habe aber noch keinen gescheiten gefunden, der sich gut integrieren lässt.
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen, bei mir bringt das insofern nichts, ich habe im Schlafzimmer
keinen Fernseher und ich will nicht immer dunkel haben, nur weil ich mich auf Sofa setze
zum Beispiel.
Ah ja, das sind ganz normale Load Cells hier, kannst du die für 2,50 Euro bei Amazon kaufen.
Das sind Load Cells, das hier ist wahrscheinlich irgendein Load Cell zu Analog-Digital-Converter-Ding
und das ist ein ESP.
Das ist ein D1 Mini, glaube ich, sieht zumindest so aus.
Das war ein DIY Projekt mit dem Raspberry Pi, ich werde ein paar von seinen Videos zeigen,
wie er all das gebaut hat.
Während du die sehen, solltest du dich auf alle Smart Home abonnieren.
Er macht Videos über Smart Home-Devices, Dashboards und Home Assistant und wirklich,
ich lerne immer was von ihm.
Ok, hier ist eine Automation von Victor aus Deutschland, und nein, das ist nicht der
gleiche Victor, der den Switchbot hatte, der ist total ein anderer Victor, der ist
ein bisschen wild.
Ok, das bedeutet, die Idee finde ich nicht so clever, weil es macht ja alles nur lauter.
Also dadurch, dass du mehr Krach hast, geht die Musik lauter, das heißt, du hast noch
mehr Krach.
Also mag für dich in der Küche vielleicht cool sein, aber für die Leute hier, die
noch im Haus wohnen, ist es eher nicht so geil.
Ja, das stimmt, da hat er voll und ganz recht, das ist übrigens auch das, was ich immer
sagt, wenn es ums Thema Heimautomatisierung geht, so Sachen musst du machen, weil das
sind die, die dir wirklich was bringen, also das sind die Dinge, die dein Leben einfacher
machen.
Dein Leben wird nicht einfacher dadurch, dass man überall einfach blind die normalen
Deckenlampen durch RGB-Lampen austauscht oder sowas, oder irgendwo mal einen Alexa hinstellt
oder sowas.
Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Du musst dir die Sachen raussuchen, die dir auf den Keks gehen und die gezielt automatisieren,
weil dann hast du auch einen Mehrwert, dann hast du auch was, wo du das ok, hat sich
gelohnt, dass ich das gemacht habe.
So ein Kontakt-Sensor, das ein Amazon-Routine schlägt, wenn es öffnet und schlägt.
Unser Exhaust-Fan ist super laut und wir hören meistens Musik, während wir kochen.
Sobald wir so schlägt, werde ich diese Automation jetzt implementieren.
Das macht mich ein bisschen...
Diese Dunstabzugs-Haube, jetzt mal ernsthaft, da war das Design doch vor Funktionalität
da, oder?
Kannst mir dann erzählen, dass das ordentlich was taugt.
Das Glas ist komplett fettig ohne Ende.
Na ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen, wenn der 2,5 Jahre alte Sohn nicht gerade so den Lightswitch
erreicht, spätestens in 2 Monaten erreicht er ihn wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Das finde ich gut.
Einfach einen Cooldown einbauen.
Okay so, das nächste Automation ist nicht ein user-submitted-One, ich stumpele es
gerade auf Reddit und hatte es einfach mit euch teilen müssen.
Das ist schwarze, das ist so ein typisches Kokona-Dick, Alter.
Sich auch Spaß gegenseitig anschießen ist typische Kokona-Sache.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock das zu testen, weil da müsste ich ja jedes Mal den ganzen
Müll in meinem Raum aufsammeln.
Das ganze Bild ist wahnsinnig und wahrscheinlich eine der coolsten Dinge, die ich je gesehen habe.
Jetzt geht's auf den Weg nach Ontario, Kanada.
Ja, das sieht aus wie Kanada, nur etwas kälter als wo ich wohne.
Sammeln wir's together.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob er den Modell Dump Truck gekauft hat, um die Automation zu erklären, oder ob er ihn bereits hatte.
Egal, ich mag ihn.
Also haben sie anstatt einen Kontakt-Sensor modifiziert, um ihn schockresistierter zu machen,
so dass es so gut wie möglich wettbewegt, wenn man ein paar Teile benutzt.
Dann haben sie anstatt ein Kontakt-Sensor modifiziert, um ihn schockresistierter zu machen,
Dann haben sie anstatt einen Kontakt-Sensor modifiziert, um ihn schockresistierter zu machen,
so dass es so gut wie möglich wettbewegt, wenn man ein paar Teile benutzt.
Es ist wirklich beeindruckend, dass jemand einen Sensor modifiziert,
der im Kanada auf einem Dumpster überleben kann.
Oh oh, es sieht so aus, als ob jemand ein Dumpster getroffen hat.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, was er mit diesem Typen machen wird, wenn er weiß, wer er ist.
Das nächste Problem kann einen großen Unterschied machen für jenseits von Menschen, die ihn benötigen.
Frank aus den USA haben eine Automation gegründet, die beweisen,
dass jemand zu hoch auf einer hohen Thermostat-Versuche herunterkommt.
Das wird es wieder auf ein besonderes Level setzen.
warum hat dieses ding nicht eingebauten limit ich hasse diese diese undurchdachten fertig smart
lösung warum hat das thermostat nicht einfach limit wo ich das in den settings einstellen kann
das ist doch das banalste auf der welt common for those who are monitoring their elderly parents with dementia or poor vision many of them don't want to be completely locked out of their thermostat so this could be a nice way to gently help them out nest and eco be will let you set temperature limits but if you have something like why is this could be a good option for you there's a lot of reasons i want to show you spätestens seitdem die alle kameras streams über irgendeinen china chinesen surfer geleakt haben like gas or pet
ich interessiere mich für lost ark aber ich hab keine zeit noch ein zweites mmo zu kreisel kreinden
is from denmark and it's very creative nikolai set up an automated bar that opens itself it's all set up using a google home routine so when anyone tells google to open the bar it opens up super impressive
na super na geil dann sag ich google macht die bar auf dann geht die bar im zeitlupentempo auf und dann muss ich noch reingreifen mir was einschenken also dann kann ich auch das sind so sachen dieses reine spielerei dann kannst du auch schnell aufziehen und reingreifen und ins glas rausholen das macht ja dann keinen großen unterschied außer dass es cool aussieht
is wowing everyone who visits using some old ikea furniture this was built by adding a sliding bed and a stepper motor which is a platform on custom 3d printed gears the stepper motor controller and arduino open the door until it hits the limiter switch and of course there's an addressable led strip which looks awesome also everything is plugged into an ikea tradfree smart switch so you can trigger it with google and if you wanted to build it and you don't drink i'm sure there's other ways you could use it you can put six packs of beer
so die instructions link below i can't wait to see your automations okay nice ich finde das immer echt gut die videos die er machte hast du danach ein zwei sachen im kopf wo man sich denkt da können wir mal ausprobieren
so was haben wir jetzt sonst zu bieten vielleicht vielleicht empfiehlt uns youtube noch irgendwas gescheites lego experiments vorher komm wir gucken ein klemmbausteine video
huge wheels kogas time
ach ja na dann ok das rad ist vielleicht nicht so ganz rund
scheinlich zu funktionieren
ok
und und weiter
ja ok
so
So viele Kugels!
Nice!
Oh, das war so fehl!
Ah, gut!
Gut, dass wir uns das jetzt angeguckt haben.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Next!
YouTube möchte uns das um, dass wir das GameStar Video gucken.
Wir gucken aber nicht das GameStar Video.
Direkt outplayed, outsmarted.
Jetzt empfiehlt uns das YouTube nicht mehr.
So wirklich spannend ist das nicht, was heute empfohlen wir, ne?
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Zeigt mal her.
Vmware HomeLab Tour 2022 Serverroom mit LED.
Wichtig, wichtig Leute!
Merkt euch, wenn ihr irgendwelche Server und Technik bei euch daheim hinstellt, das geht heute nicht mehr einfach so.
Da muss LED und mindestens, eigentlich ist RGB-LED schon Pflicht.
Zeigt mal her.
Also ohne LEDs kannst du einpacken, ja?
Der Geschwindigkeitseinbußen ist einfach zu hoch.
Als Mindeste, was du da haben musst, RGB-LEDs.
Addressable, dass du einzelne steuern kannst.
Ich dachte, das geht jetzt so weiter.
Man hört im Hintergrund schon mal, dass da ordentliche Hardware drin steckt, weil es hat genug Lüfter.
Man sieht schon mal, dass es ein Professional ist.
Leute, woran erkennt ihr, dass es ein Professional ist?
Sagt's mir, woran erkennt man's?
An den Kabel? Nee.
RGB? Nee.
Werkzeuge an der Wand? Nee.
Chat, ihr legt alle falsch.
Man erkennt das daran, weil er einen Labeler hat.
Er hat seine Server labelt.
Eine Vmware Workstation, die Vmware Workstation gerunt hat.
Ist das jetzt eine Vmware Workstation Workstation?
Oder eine Vmware Workstation VM, in der Vmware Workstation läuft?
Oder was? Oder wie?
Zu viel.
Ja, 27 Schöneinheiten ist, glaube ich, für die Hype ganz nett, wenn du so einen Raum hast.
Mein Raum wäre dafür halt ein bisschen klein.
Wobei es bei mir eher die Frage der Tiefe ist, nicht so sehr der Höhe.
Woher kommt eigentlich der Spruch, was bin ich hier sehend?
Das ist mehr oder weniger direkt aus dem Englisch ersetzt.
Die haben ja im Englischen diese komische Zeitform, dieses mit ing hinten dran, was es in Deutsch irgendwie nicht gibt.
Was ist denn das für ein Video? WebAssembly verdrängt Docker?
Das eine hat mit dem anderen auch überhaupt nichts zu tun.
WebAssembly verdrängt Docker?
Das ist so, keine Ahnung, wie wenn ich sagen würde, Scheibenkäse verdrängt Raspberry Pi.
Hat komplett nichts miteinander zu tun.
Brücken werden Autos ersetzen? Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Ach, aber den Präsentator kenne ich. Aber das Video ist zu lang.
So, ok, jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst. Was hat er dann drinne? Was hat er in seinem Rack drinne? Jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst, Chat.
Super Microserver.
Der könnte ein bisschen heller machen, ist ja schön und gut, weil man RGB hat, aber dadurch ist der Rest so dunkel.
Schon wieder so einer, der einen ESX Cluster daheim hat und ich frage mich, was genau machen die Leute mit einem ESX Cluster daheim?
Muss man 20, 30 VMs daheim laufen? Also was haben die dann da drauf?
Ich hoffe vielleicht erzählt er uns auch noch, was er damit macht.
Das schöne ist ja auch, da ist der Strom billiger.
Bei uns ist der Strom halt einfach unsinnigerweise fucking teuer.
Und es gibt immer noch Leute, die sagen, der Strom ist nicht teuer genug, das muss noch teurer werden, dass die Leute noch mehr einsparen.
Ja, ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Rackmount-Server.
Das ist ein Rackmount-Server, ist ja fast schon gedacht.
Ja, und wozu? Warum?
Vsphere, ist Vsphere nicht im Endeffekt nur das Ding, das Frontend für den ESX Cluster?
Das ist die Synology DS1621-XS+.
Das ist ein 10G-NAS.
Das ist ein super fantastischer NAS für die Home Lab.
Es ist 10G, es hat einen XEON-D-Processor und ich habe gerade diesen.
Boah, ich hasse es, wenn die Leute bei einem Satz immer schmatzen.
Also nach dem Motto, so Leute, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal, jetzt gucken wir uns als nächstes das NAS an.
Boah, das triggert mich immer.
Ja, die sind gute Dinger.
Gibt da nicht mal so viele Festplattenhersteller.
Ich frage mich halt immer noch, was zum Teufel macht der denn damit?
Also es ist sicherlich cool, das zu haben daheim, aber was ist denn da drauf?
Guck mal, ich meine der hat hier oben auch immerhin...
Ne, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das sind Glasfaserkabel wegen der Farbe her, sind es aber anscheinend gar nicht.
Das sind ganz normale AJ-45, ne, doch.
Die sind aber nicht so richtig gut shielded, die Kabel dann.
Ah, guck mal, der hat meinen Switch, der hat den gleichen Switch wie ich.
Das sind eher 16XG.
Ja.
Das sind Direct-Attached-Kabel.
Ne, das sind keine SF...
Ne, das sind keine Direct-Attached-Kabel.
Direct-Attached-Kabel haben SFP-Plus eigentlich als Stecker und das sind AJ-45 Stecker.
Oder gibt es Direct-Attached, die auf der einen Seite AJ-45 haben, auf der anderen Seite SFP-Plus?
Weil...
Du brauchst das ja eigentlich nur, weil es SFP-Plus-Ports sind.
Für AJ-45 Stecker kannst du ganz normal eine Kopferkabel nehmen.
So wie der Switch blinkt, hat er auch Kastprobleme.
Sieht echt so aus, ja.
Die haben Schwatzen ist.
Ja, besser.
Sag ich doch, eher 16XG.
Besser.
Er kostet zwar um die 500 Euro, aber ich finde immer noch, Jahre später jetzt, ist das
immer noch ein super Switch.
Der hat ja auch noch relativ viel Zeug angeschlossen.
Was macht der denn da alles?
Da unten hat er noch irgendeine komische Firewall stehen.
Ja, warum er den Cisco Switch daheim hat, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Das ist der Kram einfach nur laut und, also wenn du dir ein bisschen ältere kaufst, ist
der Kram einfach nur laut für, sagen wir mal, Noobs.
Schwierig zu bedienen und stromfressend.
Was ist das?
Ah, Videorekorder, oder?
Ja, nicht Videorekorder.
Ihr wisst doch, was ich meine Kameraaufnahmen zeuche.
Okay, weiter.
Nein, Leute, bei mir kommt keine Cyberpower-USV mehr ins Haus.
Der einzige Ausfall von meinem Rack war, als die Batterie in meiner Cyberpower-USV verreckt
ist.
Und das, obwohl es eigentlich keine online-USV ist, dazu geführt hat, dass die USV, obwohl
Strom noch aus der Wand kam, das Rack nicht mehr mit Strom versorgt hat.
Also, nee, ziehe ich nicht mehr ein.
Okay, hier erzählt er, was er drauf hat.
Ja, erzähl, erzähl.
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Das dachte ich mir schon.
Ja, aber warum?
Also, VMWare ist nicht die Begründung dafür, warum man VMWare lautet.
Das Entscheidende ist, was macht man auf diesem VMWare-Cluster?
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Ja, also als Anwendungszweck ist, ich habe einen ESX-Cluster mit 5 Knoten, ick, bla,
bla, bla, ist keine Erklärung.
Du musst erklären, was hast du auf diesem ESX-Cluster laufen, was das rechtfertigt,
dass du einen ESX-Cluster hast.
Ich meine, ich kann da 40 VMs drauf anlegen und einfach überall P ausrechnen lassen.
Unsinnigerweise.
Aber wirst du.
Gerade, gerade wenn du containerized workloads viele hast, ist es vielleicht doch nicht so
sinnvoll, einen fetten ESX-Cluster laufen zu lassen.
Ah ja, Kubernetes-Cluster muss auch noch sein.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, unter so einem Kubernetes-Cluster daheim macht man es heutzutage doch nicht
mehr.
Kubernetes.
Cringe.
Wer kein Kubernetes-Cluster hat, daheim, ja.
Dann soll er es sagen.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es einfach nicht so sinnvoll ist.
Dann soll er es sagen, ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es einfacher zum Üben, aber dann
soll er es halt sagen.
Ich habe das daheim, weil ich irgendwie das lerne, weil aktuell wirkt das so, als hat
das einen Sinn.
Ich sehe den nicht.
Ah ja, gut.
Es geht wohl wirklich rein ums Üben bei ihm.
Wichtig, jetzt ist gerade Performance Boost.
Jetzt ist es mindestens ein Drittel schneller.
Das könnte man richtig cool wäre, wenn er noch einen Temperatursensor da drinnen hätte
und das er sich anhand der Temperatur irgendwie unterschiedlich LED-DR.
Der braucht den Kubernetes-Cluster wahrscheinlich zur LED-Steuerung, genau.
Weil jede einzelne LED braucht einen eigenen Pott, ganz wichtig.
Das ist auch ordentlich skaliert.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, oder auch nicht.
Alles klar, super.
Maze man, das haben wir schon geguckt, ganz am Anfang.
Wir wissen genau so viel wie vorher, richtig, wir wissen eigentlich nichts.
Jede LED hat auch einen eigenen Twitter-Account wegen IoT und so.
Bei dem könnte ich mir das tatsächlich vorstellen.
Noch mehr Smart Home Tour.
Was haben die eigentlich immer für riesen Räume mit kaum was drinnen?
Wenn meine Räume alle so aussehen würden, dann hätte ich auch kein Problem,
da überall einen Staubsauger-Roboter durchzuschleusen.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
FBI-Rate? Ja, das ist Dings hier.
Das ist... Moment.
Er ist das.
Mega.
Gucken wir uns das jetzt nicht an.
Ah, der Lockpicking-Lawyer.
Guck mal, der crackt jetzt auch schon AES-Verschlüsselung.
Der zeigt uns jetzt, wie es geht.
Dogbone.
Boah.
70 Euro? Okay, Dollar.
Warum ist die Verschlüsselung in Französisch 256-Bit lang?
Und in...
Ach nee, 120-Bit Advanced Encryption.
Plus 156-Bit Cloud-Generated-Private-Keyboard.
Ja, geil.
Cloud, was ein Bullshit-Buzzword-Shit da drauf steht.
256-Bit Cloud-Generated-Private-Keyboard.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Was ein Bullshit-Gelaber.
Du weißt ja, der Typ hat irgendwo auf irgendeiner Kiste SSH-Key-Gen gemacht.
Oder nicht SSH-Key, SSL-Gen.
Was ein stumpf Sinn, was ein Bullshit, Alter.
Oh nein.
Dogbone leckt critical information.
Easy!
70 Euro?
Kein Quake!
Ist das schlecht, Mann.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen oder Kommentare habt, lasst sie in die Beschreibung.
Wenn ihr dieses Video gefallen habt, und ihr möchtet mehr von uns sehen, dann abonniert den Kanal.
Und wie immer, habt einen schönen Tag.
Dann seht es dir sehr gerne.
Was ist das?
Oh 5vertime wieder
oh quick muffs leute quick muffs
okay das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht neun minuten an
es wird immer advanceder
jetzt wissen wir auch wie die hovercrafts im battlefield funktionieren genau
wozu sind die räder hier noch mal
das ist eigentlich auch nur weil es geht oder das hat keinen tieferen sinn das
ist einfach nur weil es geht viel interessanter wie geht das wieder
runter der lego motor kann er nicht rückwärts drehen
es funktioniert
was kann ich sagen wie kriegt er jetzt wieder runter
ok
oh jetzt wird es feifett jetzt ist jetzt ist high iq time angesagt
richtig richtig high iq kogas
ja und nächstes danke für den sub
jetzt geht es ab
jetzt fällt aber aus wahrscheinlich fällt es jetzt auch auseinander weil es
zu sehr nach außen zieht
aber es ist schneller als das andere
es sieht es sieht es sieht irgendwie ungesund aus das ding
weil der motor an der seite ist doch das macht es auch komplett wie nennt man das
das läuft ja nicht mehr rund
unwucht genau
jetzt will er es wissen
mehr gummys
cheating
oh
Er macht den Turm voll kaputt, hä, warum soll er den Turm kaputt machen?
Ne, das sieht wild aus, das sieht jetzt wirklich wild aus, aber es funktioniert voll ganz
gut, es tut und jetzt wieder runter, ah tatsächlich, es funktioniert tatsächlich, er kann in beide
richtungen drehen, das sieht aus als bricht es demnächst ab, aber es funktioniert,
na gut, er kommt hier nicht weiter, das sieht auch nicht sonderlich stabil aus, ehrlich
gesagt und der macht es jetzt easy, easy Koggers time, oh es ist auch seiner gebrochen,
okay, was auch immer, jetzt wissen wir aber Bescheid, wenn wir mit Lego ein Windrad hoch
klettern wollen, dann wissen wir jetzt wie es geht, haben wir wieder was gelernt, da
können wir bestimmt irgendwann mal nicht gebrauchen, ja was gucken wir denn jetzt
Leute, ich weiß es nicht, es ist erst 11.13, oh ja in 2022, gab es da ein Video geradezu,
wirklich, das da, war es das da, oh ja, könnt ihr euch daran noch erinnern, wo die Leute
damals gesagt haben, Max, Max, neue Konsole, oh ja, was hältst du davon und ich habe mir
damals schon gedacht, ne, ja, na ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass es ein komisches Kickstarter
Projekt war, wo jetzt, da sind jetzt ja nicht die Milliarden am Start gewesen wie bei der
neuen Xbox oder Playstation, also ja, es ist halt in die Hose gegangen, ich glaube die
Leute hatten andere Vorstellungen davon, wie die Realität läuft, als dann die Realität
gelaufen ist.
Die Sache ist halt die, ich verstehe auch immer nicht die ganze Geschichte mit, wir machen
einen Raspberry Pi mit Retro-Gedöns, jeder x-beliebige Desktop PC ist besser fürs Emulieren
als irgendwie was von diesen komischen Kisten, wozu, ne extra Kiste?
Ja, das stimmt.
Der Witz ist halt, die haben noch viel mehr Kohle bekommen und es hat trotzdem nicht
funktioniert.
Ich glaube die haben einfach die Komplexität und Probleme, die man eben hat, sowas rauszubringen
und komplett unterschätzt.
Die haben sich gedacht, oh, wir bauen da ein bisschen Hardware zusammen, wir programmieren
da ein bisschen UI und dann geht das schon.
So einfach ist es nicht, du brauchst ja vor allem, was fast drauf läuft.
Ja, das ist von der Idee her ganz gut, die Sache ist halt die, da beißt sich so wieder,
das ist halt das Henne-Ei-Problem, warum sollte jemand für die UIA was entwickeln, wenn niemand
eine UIA hat?
Und je nachdem, wie angenehm ist es dafür zu entwickeln, lohnt sich das und anscheinend
ja nicht.
Ich denke auch dazu, dass es kommen ist und es gibt ein Basis auf wahrscheinlich der
systems made worse by the fact that people were actually walking into places like gamestop or ordering them from amazon and
Receiving them before the kickstarter backers
Das war was, was ich nicht mitgemacht habe. Ich weiß auch, ich wurde damals regelmäßig
täglich irgendwie auch auf twitter gefragt, so hat jemand gesagt, uja was denkst du zu uja?
Ich habe mir damals schon immer gedacht, das ist totgebohrt das Ding
...of your early supporters
And I picked up my uja from game, a high street retailer here in the uk, on launch for 99 pounds
And there were soon problems reported with the hardware
Revolution
That it had flaky wi-fi that would regularly drop out people had controller problems with drift and sinking
And most of the games were just the same android games
that people already had on their phones or tablets
often selling at a higher price on the uja store
And the most successful exclusive game at the time towerfall it turned out only ever sold
7000 copies on the system in its lifetime
And a lot of the other games on there were just crappy mobile flash style games
So the dream quickly faded and uja as a company ran out of money
Das ist halt die Sache, letztendlich verkauft der content die systeme und nicht umgedreht
They sold up to razer in 2015 who announced that the console hardware was being discontinued
And really they just wanted the ujas platform to help them further enter the android tv market
But to razer's credit they did keep the uja servers online for buyers of the console for several years
But they were finally closed down for good in june of 2019
And due to the system's reliance on its servers that made the console and any games you buy the way
Das video ist zur Hälfte rum und es geht nicht wirklich um 2022 jetzt habe ich das auch gerade aufgefallen
Now for retro games I like the uja as as I mentioned before this really was an android box
That you could root and sideload roms and retro games onto as well
Ja was man auf jede andere kiste auch kann
And actually the uja store had lots of emulators already on there
So I did really like the system as a small cute retro emulation
Jawoll ich brauch ne 99 dollar konsole um pong zu spielen wichtig
Ich glaub unbedingt ganz ganz ganz super toll ja
That's all I use mine for for a few years
But I must admit my uja hasn't been hooked up since around 2016
Richtig und wichtig auch wie ich diese Redewendung hasse
More recent videos essentially as an ornament a decoration on a shelf in the background of my videos
But recently I discovered there is actually still a small but dedicated fan community around the uja
Who've actually taken it upon themselves
Na ja letzte posts 2020 und 2021 so wirklich aktiv sind die net
Back into the console and make it usable again since the official servers were taken offline
So after some digging around in my drawers and boxes of wires
I managed to find the ujas power supply and the controller again
So around seven years since I last powered it on
Das ist doch ein stinknormales 12 watt Netzteil oder
Let's see what happens when we turn the uja on in 2022
Uh
And at first I was quite pleasant
An dem intro merkt man richtig man hat versucht was was was
Catchy und cooles zu machen wie wiedererkennungswert war aber trotzdem irgendwie zu cringe
Now I'd read reports on forums of people powering on their ujas for the first time after several years
And the system giving them an error and not letting them access the menus
But for me on my first boot after reacquainting myself with the ujas rather weird action button layout on the controller
I was able to get into the menus and see all of the games I'd previously installed
And actually they ran just fine
And I've got a bunch of retro titles on here many of which I purchased from the ujas store when that was still live
And loading them up they appeared to work just as well as the last time I used the system
And I actually kind of forgot I was meant to be making a video
And got a bit distracted playing some of these games again for an hour or two
And the emulators I set up on here all continued to work just fine
Warum sollten sie auch aufhören zu funktionieren?
I could see an error on the selection screen of games telling me that the system was offline
But at first that didn't seem to affect anything
I already had UYAR World which has some very helpful forums and a discord channel as well called UYAR Saviors
That's full of guides and advices and community messages and history
And then the community
Okay, that's next
Ich dachte da kommt jetzt irgendetwas spannendes oder so
Hört ich muss aufs Klo
Und ich krieg Hunger
Heißt das wir machen heute ein bisschen kürzeren Aufwachstream
Ich glaub es ist Pepo-Fat-Time
Max macht gleich NFT im Klo
Ich überlege gerade es wäre theoretisch ja ohne Probleme möglich sein Schiss als NFT zu verkaufen
Weil ja die Sachen die man quasi kauft eh nichts mit dem NFT zu tun haben
Ich geh jetzt aufs Klo und dann geh ich was essen
Vielleicht mach ich nachher Stream
Entweder machen wir mit dem Microserver weiter
Vielleicht stream ich auch wenn BG ab ist ne Runde Dark heute Abend noch
Google besser nein danach google ich bestimmt nicht
Mittlerweile hab ich aufgehört nach allem was irgendjemand schreibt googlen zu müssen
Es ist eine gute Idee nicht nach allem zu googlen
Es gibt viel mehr eklige Sachen die ihr gar nicht kennen wollt wenn man danach googelt
die man zufällig findet
Gleich fände ich Sendung mit der Maus an nice
Goodluck herr fun leute
Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich heute Mittag irgendwann nochmal hoff ich mal gucken
Ihr kennt mich meistens sage ich das und dann bin ich nicht on
Lul
Bis denn machts gut, see you